if Jack McCoy said it then it's probably
true hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush law school you know
when I was growing up my parents only
let me watch a very small amount of TV
however they let me watch an unlimited
amount of educational TV so once I
decided that I wanted to be a lawyer
when I grew up I convinced them that
legal TV shows like law and order were
educational because they would help me
with my future practice so I grew up
watching lots and lots of law and order
but to this day I still like watching
legal procedurals on TV last time around
I analyzed a few of my favorite
courtroom dramas on TV this time around
I am reacting to some of the TV shows
that you suggested that I watch and if
you have other suggestions please let me
know in the comments I'll try to get to
them including by popular demand an
entire episode about suits but without
further ado let's get to the first drama
LA law for Cassell associates at the
time of your discharge mr. Cowan six
years why did you just make that sound
I have Tourette's syndrome would you
tell the court what that is it's a
neurological disorder it causes me to
make sounds or say words or twitch in
different ways sometimes I do it more
sometimes I do it less can you control
it no but not for any length of time
what reason were you given for being
discharged Noah they said I was
disruptive were you disrupted I do
market research and the office I work in
dub is in the back and they're only a
few co-workers around to hear me so far
I really like the tone that the attorney
is using with this witness he's
conducting what's called a direct
examination so it's his witness and he's
asking the questions that he wants of
his own witness and he's trying to lay
the factual foundation for why this
particular individual was let go for
health reasons as opposed to
some other pretense reason and the
questions he's using are a great example
of what you're supposed to do on direct
examination he's asking open-ended
questions he's asking you know where do
you work
were you disruptive what is the the kind
of questions that are like what happens
next those are the classic direct
examination questions that you're not
leading the the witness you're simply
allowing the witness to tell the story
and you're just simply asking the next
question in a sequence that allows him
to go down the line of facts that you
need to elicit so so far the attorneys
doing a great job on direct examination
it's a little unrealistic that he's
literally putting his hands on on the
wall in front of the jury not allowed to
do that but so far the content of the
questions is very good did they consider
you disruptive I don't believe so no
Nigar Nigar
why'd you say that sir it's all part of
Tourette's Noah would you tell the court
what it's like to have Tourette's what
it's like yeah so that might sound like
unnecessarily emotional woowoo question
what is it like to have Tourette's
syndrome
but that is a great way to build a bond
between your witness and the jury it
might not be strictly necessary but it
adds color to the story and creating a
rapport between your witness and and
garnering sympathy in a way that is
probative of the question at hand
specifically was he let go for health
reasons or for some pretextual reason is
really important in a case like this so
that's just a textbook good example of a
good direct examination in an employment
case like this well the tics and
grimaces starts pretty soon after you
wake up in the morning oh boy and then
you go about your business when you're
alone you know hollering and spitting
barking oh boy [ __ ] it's pretty weird
if you're not used to it I guess
oh boy anyway Tourette's is part of me
and there's nothing I can do about that
about that nothing further
nothing you can do about that
tell me mr. Cowan have you ever heard of
the drug haloperidol of course I've
heard of it how about the drug clonidine
I prefer not to take either of them why
they're both frequently used in the
treatment of Tourette's
haloperidol and it makes me forget
things it makes me feel totally spaced
out and clonidine it it doesn't work too
well with me or [ __ ] [ __ ]
tell me mr. Cowan did you ever call any
of your female co-workers [ __ ] I wasn't
calling them [ __ ] I was saying [ __ ]
how do they know the difference sir if
they know me they know the difference so
the burden of your behavior should be on
them not on you
objection burning [ __ ] let me tell you
about burden a burden is not being able
to go into a restaurant or a movie a
burden is is not being able to find a
woman to love you or an employer to hire
you mr. Koh Oh your attorney generate an
objection being a kid in class who
everyone pointed at but not the weirdo
with the funny disease all right that's
all it is
so stop pointing at me and stop treating
me like I am crazy oh my just stop it
the attorney on cross-examination made
the classic mistake of asking a question
that she doesn't know the answer to the
the first set of questions that she has
about his medication she knows how he's
going to answer that he either has tried
them in the past and refuses to use them
or that there's some other reason why he
will not use the medication and that's
part of her case however she then went
beyond that to ask an open-ended
question about and try to make a legal
point
about where the burden lies now that is
not a question for the witness that's a
question for the judge to determine
whether or not there is a legal basis
for the this employee to use medication
or not and the judge would solve that
that legal question before the question
gets posed to the jury
however because she has opened the door
and because she can't close that door
she allows this witness to go off on
this narrative about the burden that he
faces every day as a result of his his
his ailment so that's exactly how you
let a cross-examination go off the rails
and that's why you you make the points
that you need to make is but in this
case about medication and you stop and
then you make those argumentative points
on in your closing argument at the end
of the case and when the witness doesn't
have an opportunity to go off and again
show show his despair in front of the
jury bad move on cross all right the
next clip comes from law in order
[Music]
that's a lot of pills isn't it precisely
the amount the Gregory Loomis took over
his two years on Sentinel this appears
to be a closing argument in a case that
involves pharmaceuticals and one of the
hardest things to do as an attorney when
you're giving a closing argument is
since you're dealing with these abstract
subjects it's so hard to create these
visual metaphors that will resonate with
the jury because so much of the trial is
just dry facts and figures and I'm sure
at some point in this case it came out
that this individual consumed X number
of pills but by taking that all of those
pills or representatives of those pills
in a pitcher and then pouring them into
another beaker you just get this
striking visual metaphor that this jury
is not going to forget so that's the
kind of thing that a good trial attorney
will do to come up with these things
that will stick with the jury's mind so
that even if they forget the facts or
forget other portions of the law they
will remember that person pouring
thousands of pills into a beaker that's
gonna stick with them so that's that's a
plus lawyering right there was supposed
to help him study and achieve his full
potential but what he didn't know how
what his parents didn't know and what
the doctor didn't know was that every
one of these pills could be as lethal as
a bullet no one knew because the
manufacturing drug company never told
anyone about possible side effects of
suicide or murder tragically one of
these bullets went off that's really
great so what she's done is this is a
case involving a warning label which can
be very dry you're dealing with this
this pros that's fit on to a warning
label of a
canister of medication and and yet the
only thing that this jury is gonna be
thinking about is this metaphor of a
beaker of bullets each one that can go
off and just this mountain of medicine
that's in front of them I mean that's a
great way to really bring home the facts
and to create something that's gonna
stick with the jury so well done by the
this attorney in this closing argument
and killed Alex Garcia the Gregory is
not equivalent he didn't volunteer to
take these pills it was not his choice
he's a child and he did as his parents
told you and his parents did what the
doctor told them and the doctor
prescribed this medication because he
had been assured by the manufacturer
that it was safe I'll follow that line
and you'll find where the blame lies but
it does not stop at Gregory he is not
responsible for this tragedy uh so
what's going on here is really
interesting from from my standpoint
because so often you have an individual
who takes an act but the plaintiffs are
not going to go after that individual
because often that individual doesn't
have any money and so if you're trying
to get compensation for some injury that
has happened often what you have to do
is to go after the bigger pockets and in
many jurisdictions even if the say the
manufacturer of you know the
pharmaceuticals or the manufacturer of
some product that was was purchased is
only a fraction responsible they can be
responsible for a hundred percent of the
damages and even if that party is not a
hundred percent responsible in a lot of
jurisdictions you are allowed to get a
hundred percent of your compensation
from any one of those defendants and
then the defendant is entitled to what's
called indemnity where they are they're
allowed
to recoup the rest of the the damages
from the other defendants so say a
company was only ten percent responsible
they might have to pay the plaintiff a
hundred percent and then go after that
90 percent from the other people and if
those people don't have any money that's
what's called being judgment proof which
is that no one's gonna go after you
because that you'll you'll simply
declare bankruptcy so it's a real
problem in America where you have people
going after the big pockets who are
potentially not a hundred percent
responsible and it's also a big problem
that if you have the person who is
mainly responsible who doesn't have the
funds to compensate compensate the
victim then the the victim may not
receive compensation it's it's a big
problem
that's why that's why you often have
insurance is to to bridge that gap but
that's that's a real issue that people
run into in the legal system
no doubt about it
Rebecca Shane and her team have put on a
dazzling defense to hear her tell it you
could almost think that no one is
responsible for what happened to Alex
Garcia we're counting on your good sense
to remember that behind the impressive
display the facts remain the facts Greg
Loomis is an uncommon ly privileged
young man with a history of violent
reactions and not getting his way his
family's wealth has allowed him to
escape all the more unpleasant
consequences of his past explosions they
placed him in new schools and gave him
money to avoid hard work and to buy his
way out of tough spots so based on past
experience he expects to evade
responsibility for Alex Garcia's murder
and to get another free pass this time
from you who did this
Sentinel or Greg Loomis and how did
Sentinel give Greg Loomis his pattern of
violent behavior his motive and the
sense of entitlement that made him think
he could wrap her garage around Alex
Garcia's throat and get away with it oh
boy okay so this is a criminal
prosecution and apparently the
defendants are using the the argument of
an intervening cause and this harkens
back to a debate that lawyers and
philosophers have had for centuries if
not millennia which is who's responsible
when there's more than one cause you
know an individual is responsible for
their own actions but there can be
intervening causes as well and that's
what the defense is saying they're
saying that but for the drugs that this
individual was consuming he would not
have conducted these particular acts and
therefore that should be a defense and
this debate goes on in the law all the
time there's a debate between what is
the what's called
proximate cause and what is the legal
cause there can be more than one reason
why something happens and it's a hard
decision for the law to make to
ultimately say who's responsible and in
what proportion so law students deal
with these questions all the time how do
we survive as a society if no one is
accountable for their actions we don't
no one here is willing to take
responsibility so the task falls on you
the law says he must be held accountable
for his actions uphold the law
there isn't an excuse for everything now
in real life the jury would not just
come up with whatever rule is
responsible in apportioning the blame
here the judge will debate that with the
other attorneys and they will come up
with jury instructions that both sides
will be responsible for writing down the
instructions that they want the jury to
get from the judge and the judge will
then choose a set or or write their own
and then give those instructions to the
jury and you have to give very clear
instructions so that the jury knows what
standard they're applying because the
jurors are just like you and me they're
lay people who are not familiar with the
mountains of you know of legal
jurisprudence that are out there so
they're going to have to be given very
specific instructions and this debate
about who is ultimately responsible
there will be a very specific
instruction about whether it is proper
to hold the individual responsible or
whether there can be an intervening
cause
[Music]
dramatic music throughout the people be
Gregory Loomis on the count of murder in
the second degree how do you find we
find the defendant Gregory Loomis guilty
[Music]
furious dismissed with the thanks of the
court man they left out the jury
instructions I really would have liked
to have seen what instructions the judge
gave the jury so that they could make
that decision
[Music]
Jack McCoy said that the law requires
them to find that that individual guilty
so if Jack McCoy said it then it's
probably true all right the next scene
comes from the TV show suits
mr. Evans is it true that you were
living with mr. Ross in and around the
time he claims to have attended Harvard
yes we shared an apartment of 5307
Huntington Boulevard in Brooklyn and how
exactly did he pay his rent he worked as
a bike messenger and made money on the
side taking the LSAT for people
oh wait I'm confused why would he have
to resort to that if he were a college
graduate because he wasn't a college
graduate what you mean he never
graduated from college no he was kicked
out of college for cheating on a test
unclear how this witness would know that
information he could be relying on
hearsay or he could be relying on things
that are outside of his personal
knowledge I think a good objection here
would have been either lack of
foundation that they haven't hasn't
shown how he knows this information or
an objection to speculation or lack of
personal knowledge if he has no basis
for knowing that information well isn't
it possible that while he was living and
this attorney makes the classic TV move
of walking right into the well of the
court the area between counsel table and
the judge the reason that there are
bailiffs is to protect the judge and
possibly the jury and if you walk into
the well unannounced you were going to
get tackled by that bailiff you have to
ask permission to enter that space for
the protection of the jury and for the
protection and the judge it happens on
TV all the time it never happens in real
life also there's usually a bunch of
clutter and stuff in that area but do
not make the mistake of walking into the
well of the court without permission
that is that is a recipe for being found
in contempt or pissing off the judge and
you don't want to do either of those
things living with you he went back to
school and completed his degree well I
don't see how since most of his spare
time spent sitting around
smoking weed with me well let me get
this straight before he was employed at
Pearson Specter to the best of your
knowledge he worked as a bike messenger
and a part-time LSAT imposter apart from
the attorney putting her elbow on the
witness stand it's a good question
to narrow things to his personal
recollection and only testifying to
things that he observed in the presence
of the defendant in this case there
should have been some objections you
want to break up the flow of the other
side if they're making some really good
points and also you may prevent them
from getting certain evidence into the
court if you're able to show that they
haven't met the evidentiary burden in
this case personal knowledge er or
foundation you don't want to let the
other side go off on and get momentum in
their questioning especially when
they're making big points against you
yes one last question mr. Evans is it at
all possible that Mike Ross ever
attended Harvard Law School not unless I
had a satellite campus at 5307
Huntington Boulevard in Brooklyn
unclear that this witness would know
what kind of time constraints are on law
students or how he could know whether
anyone could possibly go to law school I
mean he doesn't have any knowledge about
what the schedule of a law student is so
that again would be a good opportunity
to object and to prevent that testimony
from coming in because doesn't sound
proper to me based on on that foundation
all right so those are some of my
favorite legal TV shows if you enjoyed
this video and like to see more lawyer
Reax videos or hear about my law school
experience click on this short playlist
that I put together it includes my
reaction to some of the most famous
legal scenes in the movies and please
subscribe so you don't miss out on the
next video
otherwise I'll see you in the next one